khoa 1 năm tháng 12 năm, theo phân công của Chivy đại đổi 2, từ đoàn 1,
lưỡ đoàn công bình nằm 1, quân khu ba, thực hiện nhiệm vụ tại đặcu khu tốt, tình quân ninh,
cho ca làm việc của bốn đồng chiếc, ra trung quyến đến thế giống,
chung lợi chừng phủ chắc khu cộng các đồng chiếc, thực hiện những mạnh cơ,
chung si trình quân quả, Hà Si vũ và mình.
Và lúc mấy bẩy dừa bố mấy làm phút cùng ngày trong khoa chình thực hiện nhiệm vụ,
Hà Si vũ và mình có hiện tượng ná xa trên nóc công chình bị chiếc chiếc với của chùi với nguyễn thế giống đặc nữ.
Ngay lật tức, đồng chi bình trải đến đầy đồng chiếc giống gia đề tránh bị chiếc sật lợi
thì bị mồ khối lượng đất đá lớn đẹp vàng người.
Ngay khi phát hiện sự việc, theo tăng đến đức thành, đều đoàn trường tiểu đoàn 1 và đại ui lương thành hai,
quyền đại đổi trường đại đổi 2, nhưng trong đưa đồng chiếc bình dăng ngoài để xưa kéo và chuyển đến chung tâm y tế đặcu cô tốt cấp cứu.
Tuy nhiên, theo kêu lượng của chúng tâm y tế, giờ biết thường quả nạc, lúc mề tắm dở hai năng phút cùng ngày,
Hà Si vũ và mình đã tử vong trên đường đi cấp cứu.
Hà Si vũ và mình, sinh ngày hai làm thằng chiến năm hai nghị khu trong linh năm,
quyền quả sát khoảng tây, huyện khi mà, tình hà năng cú, nay là phường khiến thay, tình liên định,
nghiệp 4 tháng hai năm hai nghị khu trong hai nghị khu trong hai nghị tư.
Đần chi bình có khoảng tạnh ra đi khó khăn, mẹ mất sống, em gái khần nhỏ,
trước khi hí xin, đậu xí mình là chiến xí không biết câu chiến ở từ lội ba,
chú lội năm, đây đổi hai, từ đàn một lưới đàn là 1 ba, quân quả?
Sự hí xin của Hà Si vũ và mình là tưởng thường xám về tình thành giữ cảm quyền mình trong thực hiện nhện vụ,
có phần tốt tham phần chất bộ đội cụ hộ thề khi mới.
trước sự hí xin giữ cảm của đồng xí vũ và mình, tuổi trường bộ tư lệnh quân quân bà đặc kiếc kêu định
tham quân hàng với cấp từ Hà Si lên thường xí cho đồng xí vũ và mình.
Đồng thời, đơn vị đã đề nghị chủ tịch nước xí tạm hơn trước bảo vệ tổ khó khả mà và chủ ím đoàn thành nhân cộng sản hủ xí miếng tạm mân khai.